this is Startalk hi I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson I'm an astrophysicist with the
American Museum of Natural History and
I'm host of star talk radio welcome back
to star talk radio and fighting all
these air molecules like what's up with
that we win yeah as I've said before the
good thing about science when a
consensus of experiment emerges the good
thing about science is that it's true
whether or not you believe in it and
climate change has taken on political
dimensions is taken on cultural social
dimensions and that's odd because I
don't see people choosing sides over
equals mc-squared or other fundamental
facts of science but the experimental
consensus is there that human beings by
the virtue of our conduct burning
sources of carbon fossil fuels among
them that have been buried for millions
of years we burn them carbon previously
underground is now in the atmosphere and
that source of carbon makes carbon
dioxide a greenhouse gas is warming the
earth we are warming and that has that
comes with consequences by the way earth
will survive this the people they save
the earth no don't worry about earth
earth will be here long after we render
ourselves extinct what happens is we're
changing the climate faster than our
culture may be able to respond one of
the consequences is you melt ice caps
the water levels rise not inches not
feet Potenza feet and that will begin to
flood coastlines some of the most
important cities in the world were built
on coastlines for the very reason that
that's how you accomplish trade so it
made those ports successful so the very
foundation of our civilization requires
coastlines
that existed at a time when there was
not global climate change the kind that
would be warming the earth so get ready
for that it's going to redraw the maps
of the world unless we do something
about it
Venus suffers from a runaway greenhouse
effect it's 900 degrees on Venus
not simply because it's closer to the
Sun than us it's not that much closer
it's a little bit closer it's got a
hundred nearly a hundred percent co2 in
its atmosphere and that atmosphere is a
hundred times as dense as ours so heat
comes in it does not come out and the
temperature rises I don't want to look
like Venus
[Music]
you